so we talked about flipping we talked
about low level stuff
uh business to consumer platforms like
uber wag walking dogs
um what about like airbnb have you seen
that as as a successful model for
for side hustle like i've like i've seen
guys promote uh
programs where they're like i'll show
you how to make
you know millions of dollars without
actually owning the real estate you just
kind of lease it and they have like a
plan and a program you ever seen those
yeah i've seen them i don't know a whole
lot about them but
uh do you know that you're kind of just
like similar to uber you're kind of
building a business on top of somebody
else's
platform in a way that sort of that kind
of scares me in some ways
and uh i'm not sure what happened to all
the airbnbs
in tennessee here where i live but um i
think uh
they might be hurting right now because
of you know what's what's been going on
and i guess if if you if you have
contingency plans if you know airbnb
you know either go it's probably not
going to go offline but if they
start to cut into your your profits you
got to think about that
um but other than that i really don't
know much about it but um
those are kind of things off the top of
my head that kind of scare me yeah i
just want to
chime in on that airbnb thing because i
had a friend that used to um
i guess airbnb his place and then um
you know when they would book it he'd go
off on vacation they'd stay there he'd
come back they would actually pay for
his vacation sort of thing and it seemed
like a pretty good gig the only problem
was
uh the local government municipality
where he lives caught wind of
um people doing short-term rentals
and they change the local legislation uh
to enforce a new law that basically
taxes you for running a short-term
rental in your principal residence so
if you can picture this like you've
bought your house you pay your property
taxes on your house you know
whether you have a mortgage or not is
not relevant but now all of a sudden the
local
uh local authorities figured all right
well if these guys are doing short-term
rentals and making
5 10 15 20 000 a year
let's figure out a way to uh tax them on
it so they pass new legislation
for strs they call it a short-term
rental and i think the annual fee is
five thousand dollars
to be able to offer like your own
property that you own and you pay for
and you already pay property taxes on
so you have to pay them for that and if
if you're not paying it then they go
and enforce a levy against your property
meaning
um if you choose not to but you have
your property listed on air b
and they catch win of it which they do
because they check it now i think
there's some cross reference checks now
where airbnb
sends that information uh to the local
government
and if they catch you on it then they
place a lien against your house for the
five thousand dollars
you can't you can't discharge your
mortgage you can't renew your mortgage
you can't sell your house
without paying that lien which of course
accrues interest so
a lot of these a lot of these notions of
yeah just go to you know do this and
that likely set your house walk people's
dogs drive a car
you know all of these b2c components all
these business to consumer like
marketplaces that connect to people
they don't have longevity and they don't
have the opportunity to make the big
bucks and i think that's where most
people
focus on side hustle money like how to
make that extra
money or to build up you know like i'm
working on my side hustle but they don't
understand what they're getting into
yeah and it's difficult because i mean
the long-term things it might be slow in
the beginning but
you know you got to be able to build up
that that equity
uh or that that uh snowball effect is is
what i'm always looking for how can this
snowball into something bigger so
yeah i didn't know i didn't know that i
knew i knew in chicago with the airbnbs
i think there was some legislation
against them
that that kind of killed that there but
i wasn't sure so i think it's starting
to spread around like i know
there's some areas where they're still
free and clear but
as soon as a local government who's
always hungry for tax revenue figures
out
oh look they're doing it here and it
seems to work and they've generated x
amount of tax revenue i mean
if it's practically a wash if you're
making 15 20 grand a year renting out
your principal residence and all of a
sudden the local
uh office wants 5 000 plus they also
charge a fee for every rental
it's like dude you're charging 25 on
what i'm earning all of a sudden
and plus you have to pay income tax on
that money too
right so not only paying income tax to
the federal government i mean here
anyway
you also have to play the local
municipality a five thousand dollar fee
for the privilege
of renting out your own freaking home
right
these things erode over time
you